[Music]
fibrefind's functional precision cut
slice technology allows prolonged use of
viable human organ tissue to study
disease biology and drug metabolism
to study liver disease our patented pcs
technology begins with eight millimeter
hepatic tissue cores
these cores are cut into 250 micron
slices
next the tissue slices are cultured in
liquid media in fibrifine's patented
bioreactor
using this technology fibrifind is able
to maintain the structure viability and
metabolic functions of tissue slices for
up to seven days during this time
pro-fibrotic agents can be added to
stimulate liver fibrogenesis and
inflammation
this can also be accomplished through
lipid loading the tissue slices to model
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
inducing fibrosis results in scar
formation in the tissue sample with
emission of secreted extracellular
matrix proteins in the culture media
secreted proteins can be sampled daily
and measured to monitor disease
progression
putative anti-fibrotic peptides small
molecules or antibodies can also be
introduced they may be added
prophylactically to inhibit fibrosis
initiation
or therapeutically after fibrosis is
induced to halt fibrotic progression
the extended life of the physiologically
intact and metabolically active tissue
slices provides a window of opportunity
to test the efficacy of novel
anti-fibrotic drugs in this way
fibrifine's pre-clinical platform is
unsurpassed as a bridge to clinical
studies
using fibrefind's patented technology
pcs cultures have been successfully
prepared from a range of human organs
this can lead to novel therapeutics in
the research of organ disease
for more information about precision cut
slice technology contact fibrefind